surtout
[Musique]
l'instant le reste de l'actualité depuis
le début d'année vous avez envie de
faire quelque chose sur la citadelle
on sait plus penché sur les animaux en
voie de disparition ou voir comment ils
sont traités à la citadelle on a entendu
qu'il y avait un lémurien très rare qui
a été toutefois de la voir des soigneurs
des vétérinaires les gens qui
travaillent pour ces espèces protégées
pour soigner des animaux
on a contacté la directrice pour savoir
si vous pouvez venir à la citadelle à
poser des questions aux soigneurs on
était renner et des espèces protégées à
la citadelle
ça va être votre angle concernant le zoo
et bien alors c'est parti pour notre
seizième reportage
moi
emma faustine et yanis ont rendez vous
avec mélanie l'une des deux vétérinaires
du zoo qui va leur permettre de vivre un
moment très intense en émotions ils sont
autorisés à découvrir la pièce qui
abrite depuis trois mois la petite soit
bébé propithèques couronnés que toute
l'équipe du zoo bichonne le petit animal
est en effet nourri au biberon faute
d'avoir pu téter sa mère à la naissance
quand vous est fait pour alterner de
nuire les soigneurs pour nourrir on a
dans toutes les nuits en fait il ya une
personne qui est préposé aux aubiers pro
nage donc on a un calendrier
chacun fait nu par semaine presque parce
qu'on est on est neuf 9 ou 10 personnes
en alternance et donc on dort ici et on
prépare les biberons essayé on nourrit
ici et ensuite le matin on passe le
relais en personne qui sont journée
[Musique]
cette naissance est exceptionnelle car
dans le monde seule sept parc accueille
sept espèces de lémuriens de madagascar
et sur les vingt individus hébergé ne
subsiste que 5 femelles capables de se
reproduire
en réalité c'est une espèce qui est
menacée dans le milieu naturel et le
fait de les avoir en zoo bah ça permet
de sensibiliser les visiteurs et du coup
de récolter des fonds pour pouvoir
protéger la forêt qui qui est le lieu de
l'habitat en fait de ses cousins
sauvages et sur les 200 espèces
présentes sur l'ensemble du parc 70%
sont protégées menacées dans leur milieu
naturel par l'homme et les dégâts qu'il
cause sur l'environnement nos reporters
comprennent alors le rôle essentiel que
joue l'équipe de soigneurs de la
citadelle sont des animaux qui sont
précieux qui sont vraiment rares donc on
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
donc oui il ya quand même une pression
particulière sur ces espèces là on
n'hésite pas à demander des conseils
on discute entre soigneur dans
différents par des vétérinaires discuter
entre eux des directeurs de par geri
discutent entre eux aussi en fait on
fait partie de ce programme d'élevage
européen et donc on échange nos
individus avec d'autres parcs pour créer
des nouveaux couples par exemple comme
ce fut le cas pour les parents de la
petite soa que l'équipe prend soin de
mettre au contact de sa maman tous les
jours malgré son nourrissage barre
l'homme en matière de sauvegarde des
espèces en danger la citadelle a ainsi
acquis une vraie réputation au niveau
mondial on va cibler sur des espèces qui
ont un intérêt au niveau la conservation
c'était qu'on va pas faire du gros du
beau et du clinquant on va faire du
plutôt du petit et du rare c'est
vraiment ce qui caractérise la
collection animale de besançon
sensible aux arguments de la vétérinaire
l'équipe du jour prend le temps d'aller
à la rencontre des animaux mais aussi de
l'environnement
découvrant ainsi que le respect de la
nature va bien au delà du zoo est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres espèces en voie de
disparition qui sont pas dangereux moi
j'ai un poste un petit peu particulier
c'est je m'occupe aussi des espèces qui
sont pas obtenues en captivité dont
qui-vive naturellement sur sur le site
en particulier du coup le faucon pèlerin
qui ni jean les falaises et du coup il
ya un enjeu de conservation dessus et on
veille effectivement à préserver sa
tranquillité
la citadelle a donc gardé son rôle de
vigie
gageons que nos reporters nous la
regarderons plus tout à fait comme avant